we'll test every resident and every
member of staff in our elderly care
homes in England between now and early
June early June has come and gone
the government's promised to test every
resident in care homes left unfulfilled
new data shows that in fact 1/3 of all
residents haven't been tested at all
despite that commitment to a universal
rollout
a survey by the data analysis Bureau
also suggests that some 15% of care
homes have not had any residents tested
as any stage and nearly half of
residents haven't been tested in the
last month
I think it's disappointing because you
know we have stressed from the very
beginning that testing was the key to us
making sure that we had a good handle on
where the virus was and to try and
contain it within the care home
communities so it is disappointing to
think that only 50% of residents have
had those tests Britain's care home
residents have accounted for nearly half
of deaths to the virus in the UK there
have been failures in providing staff
with personal protective equipment and
many families of residents in care say
that once again they've been let down
I think these figures will be hugely
concerning and hugely disappointing for
the many relatives and friends of those
old people receiving care who were
promised by the government that this
testing system would be rolled out and
there every resident and Stockman that
would be tested to try to prevent the
spread of this virus and we haven't
learned lessons from elsewhere in the
world about test test tests being the
routes to saving lives data was
collected from 32,000 residents for the
study it found that while testing has
increased hugely from mid-may just one
in 10 residents were tested in the last
week a spokesperson for the Department
for Health and Social Care said we have
achieved our target to offer testing to
every care home for the over 65s
or those with dementia in England by
June the 6th we sent more than 1 million
test kits to almost 9,000 care homes but
these latest test figures suggest
renewed effort is needed to ensure the
most susceptible to the virus are being
tested Jenny Longden Sky News